[Music]
you collect things you're a famous
collector of things and you love you
know some people who make it in show
business collect sports cars or
something like that you sort of like
what would you say like could have
kitschy items or odd items or just
random thing I would say all of that
like I like kitschy stuff and I like
weird stuff and I like I mean if
somebody gives me two of something I I
go okay it's an official collection now
I collect I mean I don't collect anymore
I stopped you saw has exactly what a lot
of kid is your house just filled with
three times I filled my house up and
moved it all out and emptied it all of
us think now this is better and then it
got all filled back up again right and
you brought some stuff today just to
show us what kind of stuff you collect
you enjoy I always feel like this is a
test to prove like am I really weird or
not so this is like you yes you be the
judge yeah you guys decide if this stuff
is weird what are you gonna show it well
here this is one one item right here oh
my god it's a Miss what is this this is
obviously it's mr. Chi with a bank it's
a mr. t Bank
oh my gosh yeah I always keep changed
here look at that put it in the top of
this mohawk there you go go ahead put
more in okay
I don't get why this is funny all right
I see what you're doing yeah I know look
I make a lot of money coming up what
else well see well this one this very
simple hand soap very clever
hey up in the middle of the night ya
realize how funny that was yeah this one
this is a really odd thing I don't know
what this is no idea it looks like a
little house it's a little house it
actually glows in the dark
yeah and this is what it does see if you
can figure out why hi why the hell does
the house
it's fantastic I love it this is my last
thing I wanted to show you this is
called the autograph hound the autograph
and it's covered with autographs of oh
look at that it looks like it's from a
long time ago is it an old label the
autograph hound that is so cool and it's
rotted because I was thinking maybe you
would add your signature - that is so
nice check this out Chris Walken sign
this these are real oh yeah yes so Jon
Voight signed it yeah look at this Tim
Burton's Warren Beatty
you've got Warren baby signature right
there that is fence huh I'm in pretty
good company here yeah don't write too
big this pen says it washes off easily
huh all right I'll put my little Conan
O'Brien right there oh wow I'm in good
company oh my gosh would you sure of
course yeah that's so cute
oh I gotta ask you about this one you
didn't show it but I have to ask you
about it Oh what is this
it looks can anyone figure this out what
this is people are saying dirty things
actually right now I'll tell you I'll
give you a hint it plugs into your car
lighter uh-huh and you can cook hot dogs
in your car
[Applause]
we should go somewhere in let's take a
trip and you and I will cook hotdogs the
whole time
you